e aí é que se foi para tubos e estiver
tudo bem então tá bom então é comigo não
tá melhor coisa o que o meu quarto tá
uma bagunça tão desgraçada a que a
bagunça do meu quarto gente não é normal
que toca fogo em si ele tem que dizer
alguma coisa na vida de um tabu é o fã
de onde saiu em um foguete está do meu
lado não quer outro a ícaro que o fundo
no meu carro e meu carro furou o pneu na
eu fiquei por jacques no cantor só
colocar esse dia foi dar banho não achou
e aconteceu com meu cachorro self fugiu
só correndo captura todo tempo na certa
você pode pensar o quarto e nem e
desarrumado e só está inventando isso
porque ele quer sem graça no outono não
gente meu quarto é muito bagunçado gente
que meu quarto tinha 16 anos e samuel
robinson viajo muito e eu só entro no
meu quarto a pegar alguma coisa já vou
portugal e acabei ficando muito alto da
montanha quando eu vou arrumar meu deus
do céu eu deveria receber um salário
mínimo tomar meu pai que é ser visto
assim pessoa de seu time e forma meu
quadro hoje vai meu pai e comecei a
pegar uma só pedro león foi desenrolando
onde nem todos em rolante comecei a
puxar meu som em um show eu quero dizer
é isso meu deus fez meu deus meu deus
meu de que o puxão ele evolta vivo a
globo chegou tudo vê um mendigo junho
vende domingo embarcou lançam puxar meu
é só dizer sai lo ou está querendo dizer
que tinha um médico morando embaixo
seleção não eu levo até ontem só tinha
duas famílias morando embaixo da eleição
minha gente o pior que pra gente que a
adolescente às vezes nem é bagunceiro a
minha mãe desse imenso bairro mas seu
quarto falou meu quarto estava bagunçado
ela fala meu filho olha o ninho de pôr o
que esse é o quarto tá meu quarto não
está desarrumado manhã as coisas que
estão colocadas em lugares estratégicos
para facilitar a minha localização sobre
eles eu já corre logo ela antes de dizer
que vai sumir porque minha mãe ela grita
por deus e o mundo que um dia vai sumir
eu juro a vocês que eu esperava que
minha mãe dizer se a qualquer dia eu
posso me apegar ao bom dia jogar no chão
se podia pouquinho de fumaça resume e o
isso porque você não tira um dia pelo
menos um a mais que o quarto todo minha
gente eu tenho
o polonês do tempo aqui fora e sempre
vou amar meu quarto eu comece pela cama
eu vou subir na cama assim o papo de
afastar a cochilar no final eu vou fazer
assim o que eu vou fazer eu mudei tanto
um pouquinho é bom a gente na cama
deitando na face no outro aí eu durmo eu
acordei pensando meu deus eu falei na
missão eo meu banheiro gente pra quem
não sabe o meu banheiro é dentro do
guarda-roupa e isso mesmo a miami reinar
no domingo com azóia no mercado bem que
balanço você votar sobretudo a mão na
bola
ontem enquanto o dólar aqui também na
direita um dia antes de viajar eu tenho
um homem já no banheiro fome já é grande
não foi fame já normal só que nenhum dos
dois seguintes
aí eu viajei minha gente quando eu
cheguei de viagem que eu fui aqui eu
abri a porta de banheiro falei morrer
morreu certeza que morreu alguém aqui
dentro onde pode gente nunca esquece de
dar unificar nem se sabe do que eu sou
rica vou comprar casa que meu quarto vai
ter treino tão o acende a luz eo ar
condicionado e arrumar o quarto com o pé
tá botando o samu e às vezes até muito
na boca porque como eu falei com ele tá
bagunçado você sabe mexer nessa bagunça
agora quando a mãe no carro para o meu
deus meu deus do céu o notebook está em
cima da mesa com a placa o notebook está
aqui você não acha agora quanto estava
não sabe você sabe direitinho néctar de
notebook é já certo tamanho de barra
aquele mendigo e 14 conexão da pessoa e
acomoda muita pessoa a pessoa te ver se
a nossa família câmara gastou na cama a
vocês um filme olha achei que no
computador mesmo que na tam atua com
fome e quer comer alguma coisa não vou
lá mas combinou comigo aqui na cama eu
como um pouquinho pra te digo aqui ainda
bem que a privada não é do lado da minha
cama e pelo menos uma vez na vida
levanta a minha cama volume banheiro ou
apaga tudo bem estava com saudade de
vocês está com fome tem vendido não 4% e
você como eu quero que você comente aqui
em baixo como coisas 59 eu quero ser
como ele aqui embaixo que você mais
odeio quando seu porta bagunçado o que
você mais gosta quando eu atuava no site
você gostou do vídeo em que gostei aqui
no youtube você viu esse vídeo que leva
o facebook e volta no facebook da
partida
mais e mais se inscrevem tohmatsu do
canal se escreve o canal se inscreve no
canal quando peguei um vídeo novo enem
vai precisando um tanque não se precisa
é nós falou e ter